well I heard that I heard that music
actually helped you with your accent
like breaking your accent cuz I I feel
like that helps me whenever I I grew up
seeing classical music and it helped me
take out the twang whenever I think so I
can put it in and take it out is you
have one when I talk I do when I talk
especially if I'm tired or drinking
um but really hit Tom then um but no but
I heard that music actually helped you
like break your accent right yeah I
think I think it I listen to a lot of
Eminem like a like a a terrible amount
of Eminem so you sound like a tough
American when you it was like Detroit it
was you know had like a big sort of sort
of thing to it and I still love that man
so much and I I have I feel like more
and more I have to thank him so much you
know for well he's incredible yeah I'm a
huge fan as well yeah I just found it
interesting to break your accent you
listen to
Eminem like you're coming into your like
auditions very
aggressive so one other artist do you
like what do you listen to right now I I
mean Bon is my like number one you know
everything to listen to the National um
I listen to a lot of David Bowie at the
moment yeah I have this thing with David
Bowie it's like overrated underrated
like he's so raided yeah that then you
kind of go back and you listen to the
music and you're like oh my God this is
it's really good it's so artistic it
sounds silly though to say like David
boy is really good at doing music yes
but no but you're you're kind of right
you hit something there because people
know his name and people like I was
introduced to David Boe from the
Labyrinth yeah yeah yeah I mean it's the
cool huge Labyrinth fan and that's how I
got to know but I know his name more
than I knew his music and then when I
got into music I just started really
delving into like his catalog and he I
get what you're saying he's got an
incredible cat he's like an artist just
across everything you visual like yeah
it's everything do you you collect
records I collect vinyl I way too much
right yeah I hear that you like actually
know about it it's stupid I don't know
anything about it yeah vinyl no I like I
have a lot of them but I'll like I'll go
to like like a Goodwill and just buy a
random
ballet Jazz thing or something and then
and then you listen to it you find but
it's kind of an interesting way to like
find music again yeah you find stuff
that you would never you probably can't
even find on Spotify and stuff like that
yeah like that's a way I found um and PE
too do you remember the Miss Elliott
song you're way too young but like there
um I can't stand the r that song like
whatever but so an peoples is the
original singer I didn't even know it
was like samples I didn't even know and
you find you find all these so many cone
West ones that you find like so many so
many so many references and then Bon
thing it's really
[Music]
[Applause]
incredible thank you guys y'all have a
great night I'm going
home